who is your celebrity mother and who is
your celebrity Mommy thank you so much
for asking celebrity mother is Angela
Bassett Angela Bassett obviously Angela
Bassett she did the thing and my
celebrity mommy Anne Hathaway it's Halle
Berry Halle Berry my mother Jennifer
Anderson my mommy would be Dua Lipa Doja
cat Demi Lovato my celebrity mother is
Lady Gaga Lady Gaga Beyonce Georgia from
Jenny and Georgia Elizabeth Olsen my
celebrity mother Michelle yo Michelle yo
Michelle yo Michelle yo Jennifer Lewis
Loretta Devine Deborah Joe Rob Viola
Davis Viola Davis my celebrity mommy is
gonna have to be Angela Bassett Salma
Hayek Salma Hayek Rachel Weiss Zendaya
Geo from twice Jessica Alba Rihanna
Jenna Ortega Beyonce but those could
kind of be interchanged you know I'm
saying Ari automatics from Vanderpump
Rules hashtag team Ariana